hi guys
so um
we're going to talk about the brain
today
last lecture i talked to you a little
bit about construct validation and
what it means to measure something and
so
i'm going to take a bit of a detour
i told you about
measurement problems
last time
if you do your measurement properly
in psychometrics if you're studying
personality if you're studying
individual differences
there are roughly six things that you
can discover
and they can be broken up different ways
that's the big five model extroversion
neuroticism
agreeableness conscientiousness openness
and they can be subdivided as you should
know because in principle you've read
the paper that subdivided them into 10.
that turns out to be quite useful but
for now we'll just
presume that there are five
and then the other
factor of human function that's pretty
easy to derive and measure is iq now iq
likely nests under openness because
openness looks like it's something
roughly like intellect which is
interesting ideas but that's probably an
ability with ideas but that's probably
measured better
by an iq test so if i ask you how smart
you are and you say you're pretty smart
that would give you a relatively high
score on the intellect scale but
if i tested your iq i will get a better
measure than that so in some sense iq
nests inside the big five model
but you can think about it as a separate
thing and i think it's reasonable to do
that so you know it depends on what
you're up to fundamentally
now
when the big five was first invented
or discovered depending on how you look
at it
as i mentioned
briefly as well it was brute force
statistics basically so the idea behind
the big five is that
the uh it's called the lexical
hypothesis and the lexical hypothesis is
that
because
human traits are so important to us
because we want to understand ourselves
and perhaps even more importantly we
want to understand other people and
because we have language
there's a reasonable probability that
we've encapsulated the structure of
human personality within our language
and so
if you analyze the linguistic
representations properly then perhaps
you can extract out the central
personality features and that's
basically what the lexical hypothesis is
and it's important to know the lexical
hypothesis and it's a bit more
sophisticated than that because
it basically presumes that you can
extract out route valid information
about personality from adjectives
descriptive adjectives from phrases and
from questions and you'll get the same
basic
dimensional structure regardless of
which of those
techniques you use and that turns out to
be
true for all intents and purposes now
the lexical hypothesis depends on its
validity
depends for its validity on the initial
claim that personality is accurately
represented within the structure of
language and so one of the things i
would say is that
there's a weak big five hypothesis and a
strong big five hypothesis okay the weak
big five hypothesis is that
in so far as you use language to
describe personality personality has a
five factor structure that's reliably
extractable
now the strong big five theory is that
no no personality has a five factor
structure and it's accurately
represented in language but when you
pull out the structure from language
what you're pulling out is actually
representative of genuine personality
now
the weak hypothesis is i would say it's
established
and it's worth knowing because what it
what it means is that if you invent a
questionnaire
that has anything to do with
self-description it might be
self-description at multiple different
levels of analysis
um like values for example
and instead of just adjectives or
attitudes instead of just adjectives i
mean these categories are sort of
unclear what's the difference between
your attitude and your temperament well
you know
it's usually defined by the sentence
that you use the words in right you
extract out the words they sort of stand
there alone they don't it's very
difficult to clarify their meaning
anyways
the lexical hypothesis i think is one of
the most well established
it's one of the most well validated
claims in psychology i think it might be
the most validated claim apart from
maybe
the work that has extracted iq out from
cognitive questions
and
basically it was brute force statistics
you know people develop different lists
of adjectives and you can complain in
some ways about how they did it and
we'll talk about that later but
because they tried to throw out the
evaluative words like good and evil for
example those aren't in the big five
um so they tried to only use adjectives
that didn't necessarily seem to be
like highly
or like valued or devalued so introvert
and extrovert well they're opposites but
you know is it better to be an introvert
it's better to be an extrovert it's like
well
it's not obvious so those all the words
that
cover that dimension can be kept in
because there's no value judgments
associated with it and the originators
of the big five theory wanted to keep it
as free of values as possible now that's
already a hypothesis right it's a
hypothesis that you can come up with an
accurate description of human
personality
even if you eliminate all the words that
have to do that are clearly valence
and uh
we did an experiment here a while back
that was pretty interesting
um we got hold of a data set of
descriptive adjectives and we put all
the evaluative words back in
so you know like nasty and horrible and
awkward and uh cruel and um and then the
good words as well you know moral
pleasant uplifting all those things and
then we had people rape people they
liked and people they didn't like using
that expanded list and we got a real
archetype in some sense of the hateable
person and a tremendous number of the
words that were used came from the
evaluative dimension so i think that
when you throw out the evaluative words
you actually throw out a lot of what
people actually use descriptive words to
describe because you know whether you
like someone or don't like someone
if someone's likable or unlikable that's
pretty
important phenomena you know i mean
you hang around the people you like
generally speaking and you don't
associate with the people you don't like
so it's a fundamental choice
but we'll talk about that later because
there's reasons that happened and the
reasons were valid and
it's not that easy to fix it and besides
that the standard five factor model has
all sorts of utility
so but you need to know what its
strengths are and its limitations are
now hypothetically what you do to draw
out the five factor model is you take
imagine the set of all descriptive
adjectives okay and then you take a
random sample of those descriptive
adjectives
so that it's not biased
you're not going to use all of them
because you know if you ask someone to
describe themselves on a questionnaire
using all the adjectives we have that
describe personality they'd be there for
like a day and so that's not very
efficient so you want to take a random
sample maybe you only sample the words
that people are most likely to use
so for example if you go online you'll
find that there are word frequency
tables you know and
most of your language most of the about
500 words covers about 80 of what you
say
so
you know and
i don't remember what the lexicon of the
typical person is i
i think it's
in the neighborhood of 3 500 words but
that might be wrong but there's like 750
000 words in the english language you
know it's an omnivorous language it just
pulls words in from all over and so you
hardly use any of those words you know
and
there's ones that are used
extraordinarily infrequently so
what you could do is you could look at
the total set of adjectives and then you
could pull out
you know identify the ones the ones that
are used you know the thousand most
frequently used words and that probably
covered 95 percent of the territory and
then you could pick out random set of a
hundred and then you could administer it
to people then you could factor analyze
it you'd administer to lots of people
then you factor analyze it you get five
relatively clear and stable factors and
the most
the the one that comes out first so it's
it's the dominant factor in some sense
or the easiest to measure or maybe the
best represented language or something
like that it's extroversion versus
and extroversion is a positive
emotion dimension
and
it's associated with enthusiasm and
assertiveness
and assertive people will say
they'll dominate the conversation with
language or they'll
well that's basically that's about the
right way to think about it um
enthusiastic people they're up for
anything you know they're the ones that
are always smiling and telling jokes and
having parties and that sort of thing
and generally extroverts really like to
be around people
so they're happy they're gregarious
they're assertive
they're enthusiastic they're noisy they
blink more than introverts now why that
is i have no idea but apparently they do
so if you notice someone blinking a lot
you can assume that they're extroverts
um
if they're not conscientious
like you know there's this idea of
people being impulsive it's a very badly
defined term so when you hear
psychologists talking about impulsivity
the first thing you could realize is
they don't know you don't know what the
hell they're talking about because
probably there's no such thing as
impulsivity
but
extroverted people who are not very
conscientious tend to
that's one of the things that you might
think about as associated with
impulsivity there's all sorts of other
things though too so
um
okay so there's a positive emotion
dimension and that's extroversion and
there's negative emotion emotion
dimension and that's neuroticism
and neurotic neuroticism seems to break
down into something like withdrawal and
volatility and volatile people are
touching
so you know they'll they'll react quite
a lot if something negative happens so
if you tease them they might get upset
or if you start fighting with them in a
sort of provocative way instead of sort
of calming everything down they'll just
ramp it up and if there's two of you
that are volatile and you're having a
conversation and the conversation goes a
little bit you know into unpleasant
territory you can really get each other
going
so
yes
is it like in terms of behavior or like
internal states both
both yeah i mean
that's part of the problem with using
the word emotion because you know is an
emotion an internal state or a set of
behaviors and the answer to that is as
far as we can tell it's both
so
now
i'm going to start talking about
extraversion and neuroticism and part of
the reason for that is because
i think the evidence
for the relationship between those
traits and the way the brain functions
functions is in some sense the clearest
now you remember the big five were
extracted out using statistical
procedures right so there's no reason to
assume necessarily that the traits would
bear any straightforward relationship to
brain function
because
they didn't they weren't derived from
analysis of brain function at least not
directly they were at they were
extracted from analysis of linguistic
representations of other people's and
your own behavior but it turns out that
there's quite a concordance
between certain elements of
neuropsychological theory and the
positive and negative emotional
traits extroversion and neuroticism and
so what i'm going to do today is i'm
going to
i'm going to i'm going to talk to you
about how positive and negative emotion
are are
instantiated in some sense
neurologically
but i'm going to put that in a
a broader picture of brain function
because
well because first of all why not and
second because a lot of the things i'm
going to tell you about the brain today
will sort of retroactively shed light on
some of the clinical theories that we've
already talked about
so so which is nice you know because one
one of the ways that you find out if
something is true and this is something
we also talked about during the last
lecture is that
it manifests itself
even when you use different measurement
techniques and so you had this
statistical derivation you know which
basically took place it really started
to accelerate i would say
first in the 1960s and then in the 1980s
it made a big comeback in the 1980s but
paralleling that were theories of brain
development and they weren't really the
scientists that were doing the one sort
of research really weren't communicating
with the scientists that were doing the
other kind of research so they were
methodologically separate they used
different techniques as well they
weren't talking back and forth much
and they were using different
measurement techniques so if they both
come up with the same thing then you
think oh well there's probably something
to that because you know the sighted
people discovered it and the people who
could hear discovered it it's the same
kind of idea
so
and you know this has been worked out
in a fair bit of detail over the last
30 years really
and so
um
the the papers that you're supposed to
read with this they're difficult papers
uh i believe you're reading gray which
is a model of the limbic system and
basal ganglia applications to anxiety
and schizophrenia
and
i think you have goals in behavior
that's the carbon shire paper
i put the swanson paper in as optional
that's cerebral hemisphere regulation of
motivated behavior that is a tough paper
and so is the grey paper and it's partly
because these guys
both of them gray's paper is a is a
distillation of a very very thick book
that's very very difficult and it's been
written twice it was published first in
1982 and then again in 1999 it's a
brilliant book it's had a tremendous
impact on psychology gray was one of
those people who he was so damn smart
it's just painful you know i mean his
reference list i don't know how many
papers are in his reference list like 2
000 and one of the really weird things
about gray that makes him stand out
among scientists is he actually read all
those papers and more than that he
understood them and so that's really
something and so gray's book on anxiety
um he's he he did a lot of work with
animal behavior and i'll tell you if you
want like solid psychological
information about how the brain works
the people you pay attention to are the
animal the the people who are studying
animal behavior and and animal brains
they know what they're doing they're so
methodologically careful they're very
very reliable and the human
neuropsychologists and the people who
use pet scanners and mris and all that
thing they're way way way behind the
animal researchers because the animal
researchers can just get in there at a
lot higher resolution and they can do
much more stringent experiments and they
tend to be
more methodologically careful and more
scientifically minded so anyways the
gray book is a brilliant book it's very
it took me like four months to read that
damn book and i mean i was i really had
to take it apart because
he probably poured 30 years of work into
it something like that and like he
worked a lot in 30 years you know he did
a lot of experimentation and he read a
lot and so he built a model of the of
the brain's function that was based on
partly on russian neuropsychology partly
on cybernetic theory
partly on animal behavior
partly on
neuropsychopharmacology and so that's
the study of how drugs affect behavior
and cognition
and then partly
partly from a higher order conceptual
perspective and then he stacked all
those things up one on top of the other
to make sure that the picture was the
same at every single level of analysis
it's absolutely brilliant work and it
took the social psychologists like they
really started thinking about gray
although he published his book in 1982
they probably started thinking about
gray seriously in about 2005. so it took
23 years for his book to start to
make its wide scale entrance into you
know the more general psychological
community and
anyways and so you're going to read this
paper which is a model of the limbic
system in basal ganglia and it's a
distillate it's 30 years were distilled
into the book and then that was
distilled into this paper so
you know it's rough going
and then the swanson paper he's another
guy same kind of guy he's a
developmental neuroanatomist and
if you're really interested in
psychology i would really recommend
reading those papers because like
they're hard going but if you get it
you you have this substrata of knowledge
underneath you that's really firm and i
really like swanson's paper the guy's a
genius and what's so cool about
swanson's paper is that
like if you talk to human
neuropsychologists you'll find that
they're biased towards the cerebral
cortex and there's sort of i think
there's sort of an anthropomorphic pride
that goes along with that it's like well
how are we different from animals well
you know we've got thumbs and that's
great hurray for the thumbs and we stand
upright but if you look at us
neurologically the big difference is
that we have this tremendously expanded
cerebral cortex especially the
prefrontal cortex and so then people
think
well because you know that's one of the
things that differentiates first from
animals and it's relatively
evolutionarily modern because the human
brain really really developed rapidly
over the last two million years that
it's like king of the brain in some
sense
and uh it's the place where all the
complicated things happen
and that's just not right because
like breathing that's complicated that's
why you don't get to control it
voluntarily and keeping your heart going
that's complicated too and so you don't
get to have a decision about that your
brain has made that automatic like
millions of years ago because
there's just no way you're going to get
voluntary control over something that's
that vital
you know so
assuming that newer brain areas do more
complex things is in some ways i think
that's actually precisely backwards it's
the old brain areas that have been
around for you know 100 100 million
years those damn things are smart
and that's why they've survived for so
long and why they're distributed into so
many different species you know like you
your brain is somewhat like a lobster's
brain it's a lot like a mouse brain and
it's a lot like a rat brain and you
might think well a rat brain isn't a
very good model of a human brain because
after all they're rats but one thing i
can tell you is that a rat brain is a
way better model of a human brain then
your model of a human brain is a model
of the human brain you know what i mean
is like people think of the brain well
they have a dopey model
use a rat as an example of course it's
it's off in some ways because rats can't
talk for example but
there are so many levels of analysis
where
you you might as well be a rat you know
technically speaking the
neuropharmacology for example is very
very similar the function of the
neurotransmitters the basic
anatomy of the structures like there's a
tremendous amount of of overlap and so
you might as well go for the
commonalities among brains before you
focus in on the differences because in
some sense that way you get the basic
architecture right
now now one of the things that's really
interesting about swanson and this makes
him and he's not a neuropsychologist and
he's not really even a psychologist
he's a developmental neural anatomist
and so there's lots of ways of piecing
of chopping up the brain you know to
look at it because it's a really
complicated thing it's like saying well
how many ways can you divide up a city
to analyze it well
there's there's endless numbers of ways
that you can divide up a city to look at
it and there's it's the same with the
brain you know because it's it's
infinitely sub-dividable
in some sense certainly all the way down
to the molecular structures and then
even at higher order levels you know
because it's so complex and it's
hierarchically structured you can just
divide it up in all sorts of different
ways and so
at higher levels of resolution there
isn't even that much agreement on how to
name the parts
now what the developmental
neuroanatomists do is that they look at
how the brain develops in utero over
time so because it's a developing thing
that sort of unfolds like a flower
unfolds you know
and you can track how the you know which
part of the early brain turns into the
later brain and so you can get some
sense of the
like it's like an evolutionary tree you
know if these three parts grew out of
this part then you can assume that
there's some commonality between them
and that can also help you figure out
how to divide up the brain and so that's
one of the things that swanson does but
the other thing he does which i really
like is that instead of bill looking at
the brain from the top down which is
what human neural psychologists tend to
do because they concentrate on say
language and you know higher order
cognitive functions
which we think of as complex but you
think they're not that damn complex you
know like a computer can can do
mathematics so much better than you that
there's not even any comparison you know
and it won't be very long before
a lot of the things that that we think
of as abstract cognition are things that
computers are going to be able to do
right they just one go tournament for
example and the computers are now better
even your pc is better at playing chess
than probably anyone in this room and
the really high-end computers are better
at playing chess than anyone who who
lives and so computers are catching up
damn fast but you'll notice that they
don't do things like bus tables in
restaurants because it turns out that's
really hard
you know well and you think about it
it's hard you know you're carrying
different size loads all the time
you have to interact socially with
people properly you have to stay the
hell out of the way you have to exactly
time when you're going to come to the
table
you know you have to you have to move
extraordinarily efficiently especially
as the place gets busy you know there's
a lot of demands on you to do that job
effectively and you know we think about
it as a low-end job but
it's not automated
the low-end jobs are the ones that are
going to be automated first and it's not
obvious that they're going to be the
things that we associated with low-end
labor you know it's just that
well
now what what swanson did with the
nervous system i love i was so happy
when i found this paper because he did
exactly with the nervous system what
piaget did with children
he showed how the nervous system builds
itself from the bottom up and so swanson
lays right on top of piaget it's lovely
and then the other thing that swanson
does very very nicely is he elucidates a
lot of the freudian presuppositions
you know so
freud of course talked about the id and
the id is this it's sort of like the
archaic brain in some sense you know
it's all where all your primal impulses
lurk
and you know he called that one thing
the id
well you might say well is there an id
in the brain and the answer is well
vaguely
the the brain does differ in terms of
the of the age of its subcomponents and
as you go deeper into the brain and
closer to the spine the brain areas get
phylogenetically older and the more
phylogenetically older areas of the
brain which are underneath the cortex
they have their own little circuits
you know and there's some commonality
between them and they do govern primal i
think of them as primal sub
personalities it's and we've talked
about that before it's better than
thinking about them as drives or goals
or anything like that because not only
do they
do they uh do they
they're like sets of associated
behaviors but they're not just that
they're also ways of looking at the
world
and ways of thinking about the world so
you know if you're angry
it's not like you're you're being driven
to use your fists that's not how it
works what happens is that the angry sub
personality comes out you know and it
does a whole bunch of things you know
it's got its own state of arousal it's
characterized both by positive and
negative emotion which is something
that's quite peculiar about anger
because it's both a defensive reaction
and an aggressive forward-moving
behavior and it has a viewpoint like
it's a biased viewpoint if you're angry
with someone all you can see about them
is how damn irritating they are and how
much they need to be defeated you know
roughly speaking and so it's a whole
personality now it's a one-dimensional
personality because all it's really got
is anger and that's not enough to solve
you know every problem but you can't
think about it as a drive exactly
because also because it's not
deterministic
you know it's even when you're angry
you have a range of choices to make now
they're circumscribed by the fact that
you're angry you know but
but it's best to think about it as a sub
personality i think you just get a lot
farther that way now what swanson did
you know how psja talked about children
infants they start out with a few
fundamental reflexes right that they're
sort of born with including the ability
to use their mouth and their tongue as
an exploratory
device
and then they have certain reflexes that
they can manifest right away and then
they have the ability to modify those
reflexes and so as far as piaget was
concerned that was enough to get the
ball rolling it was sort of like the
child was booting up across time it's
got some you know outside of the
operating system you've got some bare
processes in your computer that get it
started enough so the operating system
can turn on it sort of unfolds up into
something complex well that's sort of
what human beings do across time they
start out with these basic reflexes
that are simple movements and then they
learn how to modify the movements and
then they learn how to chain the
movements together and then they learn
how to use the chain movements
as tools in some sense as embodied tools
to pursue to
to allow
these biologically determined sub
personalities to operate in the world
with some chance of success
okay now and you can you can layer that
onto the nervous system so partly what's
happening when you get it when you get
these basic movements down the ones that
are now automatic like your ability to
grip
your ability to you know do this with
your hands and all the all the basic sub
routines you have with your body
those are automatized they're made into
little machines and a lot of them run
spinally
so
you know because what you think in some
sense is that if you're walking you're
thinking about walking in some way
that's how you walk it's like that's not
right what happens is you orient
yourself to to a goal and in some sense
you just dis-inhibit the system that
knows how to walk and then it more or
less does it
automatically and you know you direct it
and you can modify what it's doing if
there's an error but you kind of know
that right you drive to school or you
drive somewhere you're familiar to you
don't even even necessarily remember the
drive if you've done it 50 times it's
because you're basically in some sense
you're just sequencing automated
behaviors and a good thing too because
if you didn't have those automated
expert behaviors at hand
you you wouldn't know how to drive
because it's
you're just not smart you know
the time when you drive most consciously
is when you first learn how to drive
well you don't want a conscious driver
you want an unconscious expert driver
whose consciousness is monitoring the
world for anything unexpected that's
what you want so and that's the case for
almost everything you do
if you have to become conscious of what
you're doing the probability that you
don't do it very well is really high and
you know that because maybe you're
talking to someone happens when i'm
lecturing sometimes you know if i'm not
really on top of things i'll get
self-conscious and that's a terrible
thing to have happen when you lecture
you know it just makes you stumble if
it's going well i know where i'm going
and i have all these little routines you
know that are stories and things that i
know that they just automatically
sequence all i have to do is point the
lecture in the right direction and you
know the things that are logically
associated with the with
the direction of the lecture
will
they'll come up they're they're primed
in some sense and so
swanson
helped me understand the functions of
the lower part of the brain quite well
and then to map that on to piaget and
one of the things he helped me
understand was just exactly how
sophisticated the lower parts of the
brain are the more automatic parts now
the behaviorists used to believe that or
did believe and still believe to some
degree that
a lot of your behavior is reflexive and
the radical behaviors the guys from the
50s but more or less made the case that
even complex behavior among animals is
nothing but the chaining together of
automatic reflexes so it was a
deterministic chain of of reflexes well
you do have reflex actions you know so
if you touch a hot stove you'll jerk
your hand away and your brain isn't
involved in that it's just your spinal
cord that's involved in that
now your brain's involved when the pain
hits and maybe that's so that you stop
doing it in the future but your
the conscious part of your brain is too
slow to get your hand away from the you
know from the stove in time and so
what's happening in your body in some
sense is that you have these multiple
layers of neurological organization and
some of them are quite fixed they're
they're automatic deterministic systems
and those are things you've really
really practiced and that you can just
run as a routine
and then above that are are those things
that you've chained together but they
could be chained together in different
ways so they're less automatized and
then if you keep going up they get more
and more complex and less automatized
until at the top which is where your
consciousness is roughly speaking
you're you have to program what you're
doing you know you have to pay very
careful attention to how to go about
doing this because you don't have the
systems built into you
so you know what that's like if you're
trying to learn something new it takes a
lot of energy and you really have to pay
attention to pay attention and then once
you start to get it you know well
there's things
what really happens is there's things
you don't have to think about anymore
and thank god for that because you know
first of all you can't think that much
because you're a pretty limited capacity
processor and second the programming is
quite difficult
okay so
so
let's see here what i've got that i can
i will do that in a minute
yeah that's a good one
okay so if you look on the right there
there's a little diagram that's a
hierarchical die or a little table
really and it's talking about the motor
system now the motor system is
what allows you to output action
and
like you're outputting action at all
sorts of levels that you don't even
realize because you know you might think
that that sight is a sensory activity
for example but that that
there's a very tight relationship
between sensory activity and motor
activity so for example when you're
looking at a scene even though you don't
know it your eyes are going like this
and the reason they're going like that
is because if you held your eyes
absolutely still and you can actually
learn to do this if you hold your eyes
absolutely still your vision will fade
right out and you won't be able to see
anything and it's because the little the
little uh retinal cells that are picking
up the light get exhausted and so then
they stop transmitting so part of the
reason you're zipping your eyes back and
forth is so that
you know different parts of your eye can
process the the scene and it doesn't get
exhausted and plus you're also looking
around you know and you're looking at
when things move you know you direct
your attention to that or if someone
makes a gesture so you're actually kind
of using your eyes like tentacles you
know to to to check out the the the
information that's coated in the light
and and even when you're here and that
sort of thing there's a fair bit of
motor activity associated with it you
turn your head unconsciously and there's
all sorts of little motor actions in
your ear that also help you tune in and
so those things are tightly associated
but roughly speaking
the motor output is
action
and then swanson shows that there are
these
um layers in the nervous system that go
from the spinal cord upward
the first ones are these somatomotor
neuron pools and the second are
locomotor pattern generators and the
third are locomotor pattern initiators
and then the fourth are locomotor
pattern controllers it's a hierarchy so
and the way to kind of lay piaget on it
in some sense is to think of the
somatomotor neuron pools as
simple
actions that can be implemented
automatically
and then
the locomotor pattern generator has
taken those simple actions and chained
them into
relatively more complex melodies of
action so kinetic melodies
and then
the locomotor pattern initiator more or
less decides when those kinetic melodies
should be implemented and even that can
be unconscious
and then
so it's still at that level of brain
organization it's still more or less
automatic even stimulus response there's
a way to think about it and then you go
one level higher and that's where you
get the ability to voluntarily use these
automated things so i can show you an
example of how this works so
this is called a ballistic movement
so i'm going to take my hand and i'm
going to bring it down really fast right
towards that edge okay so
all right now so that's very fast
movement now one of the things that's
cool about that movement is that
i don't have time once that action
starts
it happens so fast that it's done by the
time the
the uh information about the action
actually gets to my brain
so i actually once i let that go
i can't control it
what i basically am doing is
disinhibiting the motor control systems
that i already have established in my
psychophysiological being
i'm disinhibiting one of those and then
it runs automatically
and so that's what you're doing all the
time when you're
when you're acting in life and it's it's
kind of a neat i wrote a paper a while
back with an undergraduate student of
mine who's
who's a he was a pretty bright character
and
we got invited to do a paper i got
invited to do a paper on free will
and so we were thinking about free will
you know and
it's very interesting to think about
free will in relationship to these
hierarchies because it sort of goes like
this is that
out there in the future
you've got free will
but as the future moves towards the
present you don't like once it gets
close enough to the present
you have to have initiated something
automatic that will happen and so i i
can give you an example
people who play the piano very well they
look ahead of where they're playing in
the music
because
they know how to do this they don't have
to think about it what they have to do
is look ahead so that the part of them
that knows how to do this gets ready to
do it
and all of you are experts in that way
likely all of those of you who drive
you're also experts that way because
when you're driving where do you look
if you're a good driver on the highway
you look like at least half a second or
a second ahead
why
well because
50 feet ahead has already happened
right it's too close in time for you to
do anything about it so basically what
you're doing is you're looking at the
road
and then you're
disinhibiting sequences of action that
are
the ones that are going to correspond to
what you want to do with the road most
most adequately and as
you know the closer you get to executing
one of those motor behaviors the more
automated automated it is so by the time
you manifest the action there's no free
will there at all
but your you set it up to be released in
some sense so i could say well
this isn't there's no free will in that
but there was in deciding to do it at
that point
so and so that's sort of how
your auto automaticity meets your
freedom you've got to think about it as
something extending across time
so
okay so
having established that then we're going
to get into the
the uh the more the
neurological localization a little bit
so
you might say
well you collect all these patterns of
behavior and then you automate them into
routines i could give you an example so
for a child you know when a child first
comes when a child is first born if you
tap on its cheek it'll go like this it's
called a rooting reflex and it'll move
its mouth and tongue
but what it's doing roughly speaking is
searching for a nipple and if you just
put your finger there it'll clamp onto
that and start to suck and so the child
comes out with that ability and then
that's a reflex it's sort of built into
the neurology
but then when the child starts to
interact with the mother to actually
breastfeed well then that initial reflex
has to be modified quite substantially
in the context of the relationship with
the mother because the bare reflex
it's enough to get the thing going but
it's not enough to make it work and so
often mothers
take a fair bit of time to learn how to
breastfeed but it's also because the
baby is taking a fair bit of time to
learn how to do it so they have to
establish the dance that goes with that
and one of the things that's quite cool
about
about that dance so to speak because
there's been studies done of depressed
and non-depressed mothers interacting
with their infants and so if you take a
non-depressed mother interacting with
their infant and you just film them and
then you speed up the film you can see
like the mothers
the baby reacts in the mother reacts and
the baby racks and the mother reacts and
it's like a dance you know there's this
continual flow of information between
the two of them and if the baby's with a
depressed mother that doesn't happen
it's jerky and and discontinuous
and so if you think about that you can
see how the
you know the dialectical interaction
between the mother and child is building
up the child's repertoire of of complex
abilities
within a social context you know i mean
i know i told you guys
before that roughly speaking that you
know kids really get socialized to play
with each other
you know between two and four but
that's not exactly true because even the
lower level more automated and more
primordial
reflex behaviors you know like like the
ones that are associated with
breastfeeding even those develop under
the constraints of a
of social guidelines
so
society's always there right from the
reflex level up
but
you know what happens when kids are
between two and four is they have to
learn to actually play
they have to learn how to play complex
games with other children and so that's
a whole that involves you know
communication and negotiation at a
verbal level and and also with people
their own age so
you know it's continuous in some sense
and discontinuous in another sense okay
so anyways you might say well why do you
bother stringing all these things
together and well you think about the
breastfeeding issues well why does a
baby bother to learn how to breastfeed
well that's pretty obvious isn't it i
mean first of all if it doesn't then it
doesn't live
you know and there's a bunch of reasons
for that it's like one is obviously it's
not going to be nourished properly
although
you know there are things you can do to
substitute for that although still
breastfeeding still seems to be the best
thing you can do for your baby
although you can work around it but
fundamentally it seems to be the best
thing that you can do but then the
baby's also learning all sorts of other
things like it's got skin-to-skin
contact and it's snuggling and it's
being comfort and it's doing eye gazed
eye gaze and it's cooing and the
mother's imitating it and it's like
there's just a lot of things going on
there and so
the child is organizing all that partly
to fulfill a basic biological need which
is opposed to needs both thirst and
hunger but it's also fulfilling its need
for play for example because children
have a circuit for play so you could say
play is part of the inn
it's a fundamental biological need the
other
uh yak pancett was one of the people who
either discovered that or who worked on
it and that work was extended by tiffany
fields at uh
in a hospital in florida some really
brilliant work
she was looking at pancep's work on the
necessity of tactile stimulation
and uh she thought hey i bet we could
try that with premature babies because
you know if a baby's premature a couple
of things are problems i mean first of
all
at the end of the term pregnancy term
that's when babies lay on fat you know
so they come out and they're sort of
they've got some store storage there in
case things don't get going very well
you know and they're gaining a lot of
weight in that last period of pregnancy
so if they come out premature then
they're really skinny and then what
happens often is they start to lose
weight and that's not good because they
should be ramping up the weight gain
really quick like a newborn baby will
grow its clothes in one week you know
those things are they're they're gaining
weight quickly to do the premature
babies lose weight and you know it's
hard to keep them going they put them in
an incubator
they feed them but what tiffany field
did was she had the nurses go in there
you know with
with gloves and massage the babies for
10 minutes three times a day and those
babies gained weight as fast as babies
that were still in utero and you could
still detect the differences in their
development six months later which in
baby terms is like forever right i mean
you change as much from zero months to
six months as you probably do from six
months to 20 years old it's such a
radical transformation
so okay the reason i'm telling you all
this is because
you lay out these hierarchies of
behavior that are well practiced and
automatized and brought under the
control of social conditioning but you
really do them in the service of
of
well that's that's the question in the
service of we'll say biological
necessity for the sake of argument well
you have to eat and you have to drink
and so one of the way one of the reasons
you lay out the hierarchy that's
associated with breastfeeding so you can
do that directly
but also so that you can establish a
relationship so that not only are you
doing it directly this day but you're
also going to do it
you know tomorrow and the next day and
the day after that and so
the hunger system is integrated with
these other systems of biological
constraint in some sense and they're
trying to come up with an answer to the
continual problem so you have dedicated
biological systems that help you address
problems that are associated with your
biological nature that are universal
and those would be the things that freud
would describe as the id so you can
think of these
hierarchies of motor behavior
which sort of develop up into sub
personalities as nested in some sense
inside motivational states
so there's the
motor behavior hierarchy that you use
when you're angry there's a motor
behavior hierarchy you use when you're
distressed and kids get very good at
that you know so they'll cry which is a
reflex but by the time they're about
two they're pretty damn good at crying
you know they've gotta they've gotta cry
that sounds like they're sounding upset
when they're really angry
and so if you really listen you can hear
the difference because a baby angry baby
sounds different than a sad baby but if
you don't listen the baby will have you
thinking it's sad no problem then you'll
feel sorry for it and go you know help
it out and really it's just thinking up
yours you know
so
we know this partly because
so let's say you've got a baby and it's
under nine months it's six months old
and it's crying in its crib you think
well what should you do you go in there
and you pick up the baby and you comfort
it you probably do that pretty much
non-stop when the baby's that young you
know because they're so young they
should really still be in utero they're
they're really young but by nine months
that baby's starting to get smart and so
it's about nine months when it can
visually recognize people it knows and
and people
people here she doesn't know and so then
the baby's in there and it's you know
squawking a bit and so
wants some attention and then someone
walks in and it's not the mother and the
baby bursts into tears and people think
oh that baby's all sad because it's
mother didn't show up it's like it's not
sad it's really irritated that the wrong
person showed up and you can tell that
because people have done facial coding
of the baby's expression and also its
skin tone and an angry baby looks angry
first of all and it turns all red it's
like it's really angry and you see that
behavior later too in temper tantrums
like a two-year-old that's having a
temper tantrum is just having a fit of
rage
you know they're the rage system because
there is a rage system it's just
completely out of control it's just
absolutely dominating their behavior and
you don't really want to encourage that
because the rage system should start to
be modulated by other systems and other
higher order control systems not so much
suppressed or repressed which is sort of
how the freudians would think but
integrated into more complex and
sophisticated modes of action so the
child can use its anger which is an
extraordinary useful capacity you know
because it allows you to defend yourself
so the child can learn to use that in a
sophisticated way so that it can solve
the problems that would lead to a rage
attack without ever getting to the point
where it has to be enraged right that's
a functional child it's not like it's
learned to repress its anger it's just
that it gets along with people it never
has to get angry so
now some kids learn to repress their
anger because you know they're in a
household where
any manifestation of anger is
dealt with very very harshly you know
and maybe there's a rule that everyone
has to be nice to each other all of the
time you know or else sort of a
paradoxical rule
but anyways you can imagine now there's
a lot of these biological systems and so
i want to show you some of their
instantiation here so let's look at this
one
so
when you get up above the spinal cord
there's a little brain area i'll show
you about how big it is
there it is so there's your brain the
the
top on part the part on top that's the
cerebral cortex that's the part that
people are really proud of it's like oh
wow look at our cerebral cortex you know
doesn't it have a lot of neurons and
then in the middle there
um there are older brain areas
phylogenetically old and then as you go
down towards the spinal cord they
basically get older and older and older
and older
so and more and more
critical to your development so the
serotonin system we talked about a
little bit in lobsters right serotonin
system is the thing that sort of
determines where a lobster is in the
dominance hurricane determines whether
it stands like this or whether it stands
like this that's an old system and when
your brain is developing in utero this
it's the serotonin system that guides
its development so that's how important
it is it's sort of like the conductor of
the orchestra but it's also the thing
that
controls the entire unfolding of the
brain
and it comes from you know
really really it's a really really
archaic system so in some sense your
your your being is controlled by these
things that are ancient beyond
comprehension
you know
anyways you look at the hypothalamus you
think wow that's not very big
and
yeah it's not but if you take a cat
and you so cat brain looks something
like that if you take off all the stuff
that's in light orange and most of the
top of the stuff above the hypothalamus
that's in white just take all that out
and it's a female cat and it's in a cage
you really can't tell the difference
between it and a cat that has all the
the rest of that brain
now there's some things it can't do
it doesn't do very well if you take it
into a new situation because it can't
learn
more more importantly in some sense it
can't remember
so it's in a perpetual state of
everything happening for the very first
time but it's still capable of a lot of
the reactions that would be necessary in
order for you to stay alive so it can
regulate its liquid intake can regulate
its food intake it can react sexually
it's capable of defensive aggression
although it'll really fly into a rage so
it's kind of like a disinhibited
two-year-old in some sense you know
and uh
you know as long as you keep it in the
cage and provide it with food and water
it's like the way it lives and and it's
hyper exploratory
which i think is just weird beyond
belief it's like you take the brain off
a cat and then all it wants to do is
explore which is not what you think at
all it's like a cat with no brain is
really curious
it just doesn't make sense but it does
actually because the systems that drive
your exploratory urge
are rooted in the hypothalamus and
they're actually the same systems
the it's it's uh
individual differences in the function
and sensitivity of those systems that
are in part associated with individual
differences in extroversion
so extroverts are sort of hyper
exploratory in social situations whereas
introverts aren't and
the exploratory circuit that that has
its origins in the hypothalamus runs on
dopamine roughly speaking and then it
runs through the base of your brain and
then up into your
up into your prefrontal cortex in
particular and it's also the system that
responds to cocaine and amphetamines and
other drugs that people like to take
because they heighten positive emotion
so
so it's variability at a very very low
level in the brain that that determines
things like the differences in
extroverts and introverts so anyways
it's this tiny little part of the brain
and yet you know
if that's all you have you can get along
not too bad
um so
but that's also because
it's tiny from one level of analysis but
it's really big from another
you know i mean
you can you can increase your resolution
when you're doing brain analysis all the
way down to the molecular level and
still be looking at the brain you know
below the molecular level at the atomic
level it's sort of well everything's
made out of atoms
but the brain is already there at a
molecular level and it's insanely
complicated at a molecular level and the
hypothalamus is way bigger than a
molecule and so even though it's small
compared to the rest of our brain
it's still a whopping big structure by
atomic standards and so there's a hell
of a lot going on down there and you
notice the hypothalamus you might say
well is there such a you said is there
such a thing as the id well
yes no is it in the brain
yes no
really low resolution representation of
what's in the brain that's one way of
thinking about it but then you might say
well is there a hypothalamus
and the answer to that is well yes and
no because there's the hypothalamic
structure and you see it's made out of a
bunch of things that are different and
so you could say well should you even
group those things together well the
answer to that is it depends on why
you're grouping them together you know
if it's useful for some purpose of
understanding or control to group them
together i mean they're
they they they're similar in the way
that they emerge in the course of brain
development and they're roughly of the
same phylogenetic age but there's lots
of reasons to treat them as the same and
there's lots of reasons to treat them as
different depends on what you're trying
to do
anyways the hypothalamus has all these
little
sub
what
what do you call it substructures
that are really in some sense at the
core of the sub personalities that we
talked about
so for example
um
okay so this is this is
swanson again and he's showing you this
is a rat's brain from the bottom and
he's showing you the layout of the
hypothalamus you see it's got all those
different
nuclei it doesn't look like one thing it
looks like a bunch of things and so here
he says
the descending paraventricular nucleus
is involved in the control of eating and
drinking and that's shown in green
so that's the thing that when you get
hungry or thirsty that's the thing that
sort of turns on your hungry and thirsty
sub personality and then
the rest of the cell groups play a major
role in controlling two classes of
social behaviors that is behaviors
involving interactions between animals
reproductive as the red areas
and defensive the purplish areas
so
now what you can think is you have all
those little sub routines that we
already talked about you know that are
sort of at hand and ready to go and then
they're organized underneath these major
classes of motivation
so that you have to do something like
eat and so
they the it's like there's an eating
robot in you that's one way of thinking
about it except it's smarter than that
and it's it's alive and conscious you
know these things are alive they're not
machines and they're not deterministic
they're just sub they're partial you
could think of them as low resolution
personalities or unidimensional
personalities because the only thing the
eating system really cares about is
whether or not you eat and the drinking
system is the same thing
you know you see malfunction sometimes
in people of these singular systems so
you can develop a condition if you have
hypothalamic damage where you you'll
drink yourself you'll drink water till
you die and no one can stop you you know
they could lock you in a room away from
sinks and that would stop you but you'd
be raging away inside trying to claw
through the door to get to the damn
water because you're so hyper thirsty
that
it's
it's all that there is left of you in
some sense and if you're allowed access
to a tap you'll just drink and drink and
drink and drink and drink and drink and
drink till you drown
and you know people can say hey you've
had enough water it's like forget that
the hypothalamus is a major league
system and when push comes to shove it's
the thing that's in control and one of
the ways of thinking about the way that
you organize your your life is that
the hypothalamus controls the major
motivational systems we just talked
about those and so those are the things
that people would think about as drives
although they're not drives they're too
complicated to be drives
and then there's other systems that come
up later that we'll also talk about that
that govern emotion like anxiety
and uh and a different system that
governs pain
partly what you're trying to do as you
organize your life is to make sure those
systems stay shut off
and then you think well i'm in control
it's like well no you're not you just
satisfied all the things that could take
control from you and so now you have a
modicum of choice you can and basically
what you're doing when all these things
have had what they need is you're
running around exploring
you know and that's you know that's also
another one of these circuits because
the hypothalamus as i already said
governs exploration
so a lot of
see
psychologists often get things backwards
and they ask silly questions like why
are people anxious that's a stupid
question
it's how people why are people ever calm
that's a question because of like why
are you anxious well hmm think of all
the terrible things that can happen to
you and they will happen to you even
worse and there isn't anything you could
do about it it's like why aren't you
quaking in your boats just sitting there
well that's a mystery
you know and then
well
you know here you are in your normal
state it's like well no this is not a
normal state
people have been trying for
seven million years like as people
to create a situation so complex and
comfortable that a couple hundred of you
can sit here you know without having
your hypothalamus driving you towards
something and actually just listen to
something for a few hours
that's not normal that's so staggeringly
abnormal that that you know it's a
miracle
that the typical person like
and for most of human history it's like
you are hungry man
and that's not the same like you people
well some of you have probably been
hungry in your life but i mean
what's the longest and is there someone
here who's gone without food for more
than one day
okay has anybody here gone without food
for more than a week
okay okay how about three days
okay so like are you hungry
no
you know you're hungry when you haven't
had anything to eat for 20 days then
you're hungry you know so
and the same goes for thirst and
cold and all the things that we're just
never exposed to so you know we think
civilized people are all calm and nice
and easy to belong with it's like
yeah well you know
you have absolutely everything you need
all the time so and that makes you as
easy to get along with as any completely
insane primate ever gets
so
okay so
the rat you might say well god if you
can survive with just the hypothalamus
what good is the rest of the brain
and the answer is
well
if you're thirsty
let's say you're angry the hunger system
isn't going to be able to take care of
that right so you're hungry okay that
works you're angry that works but then
you have another problem which is
you're hungry now and you're angry now
perhaps
you can
move through those states you watch that
you see that in two-year-olds that's
partly why they're so fun to be around
it's like first of all they're really
excited they're running around playing
and then you know they trip and then
they're crying like mad and then you
poke them and they laugh and then they
want something to eat and then they fall
asleep and you know they're just they're
just running they're run by their
hypothalamus and it's really fun to see
because they're so alive and so
enthusiastic and spontaneous but they're
completely clueless it's like you take
one of those creatures to the mall and
leave it there and it's like it's just
not happy at all and the reason for that
is
well it doesn't know how to sequence any
of its actions right it runs through
these states of need
but it isn't complicated enough to
figure out how to address those needs in
any consistent sense across multiple
environments in a social world you need
the rest of your brain for that and so
and that again fits in with the
piagetian ideas that what you're doing
is you're taking these micro
personalities that are basically
instantiated within the hypothalamus
and then you're organizing those into
more and more complex games and you need
the cortex to do that because
the cortex is partly what enables you to
to think about time
you know because the hypothalamus is so
it's a here and now thing
like the hypothalamic cat lives in the
present there's the present and that's
it you know you probably get some sense
of that
like there are one of the things that
happens to people if they take
amphetamines or if they take psychedelic
drugs is that some of the inhibitory
control
some of the more complex control systems
that are cortical shut down and so then
they enter a state where
it's all now
and you know the now just comes at
people in that state it's it's a
transcendent experience but of course
you know
despite that you're not functional
and so in some sense you trade that
transcendent relationship with reality
for a narrow functionality and that's
too bad and that's life but you know
it's it's a it's a trade-off so anyways
you're organizing these sub
personalities and you're using your
cortex to do that because you know you
don't just have to think about eating
you have to think about
huh how am i going to get the food when
is the food going to come how am i going
to cook the food what about all the
other people that want to eat how do we
regulate that in our family and then how
do we regulate that with the fact that
we also need to sleep and we need to
work and we need to get along with other
people and we need to have something
interesting to do and like it's
ridiculously complicated and it really
doesn't
there's no end to the complication
because
you know maybe you're just solving the
problem for you
and then you're two
or maybe you're trying to work it out
within your family well then that's sort
of like the crumb brothers they never
get out of their family because they
just never come to an arrangement that
works well enough so that they can you
know in some sense move into the broader
world then you solve the family problem
but then you got the like the tribe
problem and you know maybe you can solve
that to some degree but then you have
the broader political problem it's like
you know there's an infinite number of
problems that crop up for you to solve
so there's plenty for you to do with
your big cortex you know and we paid a
big price for that thing because once we
discovered time
you know
we could make a bargain with the future
which is basically what you do when you
regulate your behavior you're making a
bargain with the future you say to
yourself
if i forego so and so now
then later
oh it'll pay off and that's real useful
you can conceptualize the future and you
can conceptualize the future as
something you can bargain with
but there's a lot of cost to that one is
you can't you don't get to do just what
you want right now of course that sucks
it's partly why people drink alcohol
you know because alcohol is
disinhibiting it stops you from thinking
it actually doesn't stop you from
thinking about the future by the way it
stops you from caring
about what you think about the future
and that's just as good and so then you
can go out and have fun because fun is
you know impulsive and often extremely
dangerous because the long-term
consequences you know can be really
devastating but it's a real pain to keep
yourself controlled all the time you
know because you're forgoing direct
reward
constantly you know i think it's part of
the reason why
people in heavily industrialized complex
countries aren't necessarily happy
it's like you know
it takes a lot of grinding away to keep
all the machinery that keeps all of this
in place going you know so you're not
getting typhoid and you know tigers
aren't tearing you apart but by the same
token
you have to be unbelievably disciplined
and
ready to act constantly to keep
everything that's so complex around you
working and that's not necessarily fun
so
okay
now
let's look at something else
now you can tell me if i
if i showed you this i hope i didn't
show you this
you see that
okay good now some of you know this and
so you just don't say anything
although you probably don't know this
specific version
so
you're gonna if you've seen this sort of
thing before you're gonna think you're
smart while you're watching it but it'll
probably still trip you up i hope
so give me a sec here and all
see if we can actually get some sound
out of this thing
the monkey business illusion
count how many times the player is
wearing white past the ball
the correct answer is 16 passes
did you spot the gorilla
for people who haven't seen or heard
about a video like this before about
half missed the gorilla
if you knew about the gorilla you
probably saw it but did you notice the
curtain changing color or the player on
the black team leaving the game
[Music]
here comes the gorilla and there goes a
player and the curtain is changing from
red to gold
when you're looking for a gorilla
and that's the monkey business solution
learn more about this illusion and the
original gorilla experiment at
invisiblegorilla.com
yeah so
that's quite the
that's quite the illustration so
the one of the questions you might ask
is
well okay first of all how many of you
didn't see the gorilla
okay how many of you have seen this sort
of video before okay so you knew about
the damn gorilla of the people who
didn't know about the gorilla how many
people didn't see the gorilla
well some okay fine how many of you got
the other things
both of them
okay well so you get the point the point
is and it's brilliant experiment it's an
insanely brilliant experiment
um
you're blind
to a ridiculous degree
and
your visual system and your brain are
constantly coping with the fact that
you're blind you know and you can kind
of detect it to some degree like if you
look at someone
but you pay attention to the things that
surround them you'll see that like so
i'm looking at you i can't see your
nose for sure it's gone i can't even see
your face i can see your glasses
i can't see any features in your face
golf
can you smile
no the one behind
so well one of the things i've noticed
when doing this is that like if you look
here
look at my finger
but pay attention to my face it's really
hard because normally when you pay
attention you move your eyes to what
you're paying attention to
okay so
here's what you might see the first
thing you might see is that you can't
see my nose
the second thing you might see is that
you can really see my eyes especially if
they move
weird eh
isn't that weird god it's so weird it's
like all of a sudden these eyes pop up
they're going back and forth like this
yeah so i'll try this too okay so look
at my my finger again
so you can also see teeth well why
well if you're looking here and there's
something there with eyes and teeth you
should probably be able to see it right
so what that basically means is you've
got this tiny little fovea which is
right in the center of your retina it's
just densely packed with cells and then
those cells transmit information along
the optic nerve and they're just
connected like mad to cells in the
visual cortex but you don't have that
much room so you can't connect all the
cells in your retina to 10 000 cells
like at the first level of connection
you'd have to have a brain this big you
know and you don't so you you you get by
and part of the way you get by is you're
always moving your eyes around and so it
looks like you can see everything but
but you can't
in fact out here like if i'm looking at
you now i can tell my hands are there
although if i didn't know they were
hands i probably couldn't figure it out
they're they're they're kind of blurry i
would say
and they're in black and white
but i can't tell that you know
so out here it's like who cares what
color it is so you just don't see the
color but you don't know that you don't
see the color and then of course i can
have my hands here and then i put them
here i can hardly see them and then but
they're gone
they're so gone it's like they don't
even exist it's not even you know
because you think in some sense that
what was behind your head would be black
like when you close your eyes
that's nothing but no no what you can't
see behind your head is so not there
that it isn't you know it's literally
it isn't even not there that's how gone
it is
so
okay so part of the way that your eyes
work is that
the periphery is attached to
devices in some sense and some of them
detect lines and some of them detect
movement you remember jurassic park
don't move
the dinosaur can't see you unless you
move it's like yeah that frogs are like
that and cats are like that to some
degree they can really see things move
this way partly because their eyes are
slitted makes it easier for them to see
things moving like this they're not so
good at things moving like this oh it's
because they chase mice right and mice
move most mice you know except like ones
that hop
they move this way and so cats are
specialized for that and so you're also
specialized to see teeth and eyes
because you want to know if something's
looking at you and you want to know if
it has teeth and so what that means in
part is that the the surrounding tissue
in your eyes reports to some degree to
your visual cortex which is what you use
to actually have conscious vision with
but a lot of it just dumps down into the
some of the brain areas we haven't
talked about not necessarily directly
down to the hypothalamus although i
suspect it has inputs there i just don't
know but your eyes talk to your spinal
cord directly so that you could see
something snake like for example and
jump just like your you jump if your
hand touches a hot stove you don't even
see the snake it's like snake jump
and the reason for that is you wait
around to see the snake it's like it's
bitten you 15 times and you're dead so
you can't wait around and see this oh
look a snake
and you jump it's like no
that doesn't work
so
your your body has conserved all these
layers of reflex and movement all the
way up to you know higher order
voluntary movement because otherwise you
just wouldn't be fast enough when
something super fast happens and then
the way your eyes are built so your eyes
can tell your your body to jump with no
vision right it's just pattern snake
pattern jump pattern snake pattern
retinal pattern optic dirt pattern brain
pattern muscle pattern no vision
no seeing because you don't need to see
it you just have to do pattern pattern
matching
right it's a weird way of thinking about
it but it's it's not much different than
than touching you know you can feel the
pattern
you can build a three-dimensional
representation of it you can really see
well with your eyes it's like the idea
that blind people can't see is a really
dopey idea they can't see color and
they're not very good at detecting
things in the distance but they have a
visual world it's just built out of
things that don't have color you know
you know perfectly well that that's the
case because i could hand you an object
and you could fiddle around with it
behind your back
and after some fiddling around you know
exactly what it looked like
and you know you might pull it out here
and say well i didn't know it was blue
it's like yeah okay fair enough you
didn't know it was blue but you still
saw it
and you can get pretty goddamn good
vision with your ears
so there are kids who are blind who've
learned to echolocate
so they go click click click they don't
make that noise exactly but they do
click
and they can detect the clicks bouncing
off of things and they can do that well
enough not only to walk but some of them
can actually ride bikes
it's like hey that's impressive man
so
so what's that
yeah there's one kid i saw a kid on
youtube who was blind who could shoot
baskets yeah which
that's impressive man
but you know my point is is that you
know a lot of the neural tissue is it'll
take whatever input it gets and so if
you're born blind your
your auditory systems will invade your
visual system and then you have twice as
much brain devoted to your hearing
so and then you know you can use that
quite effectively so
all right so i think we're probably
pretty much out of time the one thing i
want to tell you before we go into the
next part though is that so now we've
sort of built up
the idea of these underlying
motivational systems and now you can
kind of see how they work so you might
say to yourself
why
didn't you see the gorilla and the
curtain and the person leaving
it's really complicated it's really
complicated
well the first
answer is
you did what i asked
and then you might ask why why did you
do what i asked i mean you missed the
damn gorilla right it's like obviously
that wasn't a very good decision so you
think why did you do what i asked and
the answer would be
well it's sort of like the milgram
obedience experiment except you know at
a way level lower level it's like we've
got an agreement going on here you guys
are all very sophisticated and complex
game players you know otherwise you
couldn't sit here
peacefully for an hour and a half so
you're you're very well socialized all
of you and so that means that you've
organized all your motivations into a
hierarchy and it's and that hierarchy is
guiding your behavior here it might be
something like well we need to learn
something and hypothetically you come
here and you learn something and so
you're playing that out
and then because that's the motivational
state that you're in
when i ask you to do something you're
just going to do it well then what
what's so cool is that as soon as you
decide to point your attention at
something what happens is
what you see in the world radically
transforms you know so
i say well count the basketballs and all
of a sudden all you can see are
basketballs and you think no no i see
i'm not blind it's like well
you're pretty damn blind and so
that's partly how you can understand how
motivation is a sub personality like it
has its whole sets of perceptions and
values it's like all of a sudden
we i set you up in a little motivated
state it was a complicated one you know
but it was just like here's a task and
so you're all motivated you're going to
do the task properly for for god only
knows how many reasons and then all of a
sudden all that exists in the world are
basketballs
right and so
that that's that's that it's it's it's
as if your your goal directed attention
has transformed the phenomenology of the
world and that's something that's really
cool because one of the things it
implies is that
what you see of the world depends on
what you're aiming at
and in a real sense if this isn't some
trivial sense it means like literally
what you're aiming at i'm going to count
the basketballs it means well you're not
noticing the gorillas so one of the
things that you might ask yourself and
this is partly what the phenomenologists
were on about is what he aimed at
and
what is it that what you're aiming at
allows you to see and what is it that
what you're aiming at blinds you to
and it blinds you to a lot more than it
allows you to see and so another thing
that you could think about is like if
everything you see makes you angry and
bitter and resentful
then
you might think well
what exactly am i aiming at that's
making the world organize itself around
me in that manner and that's you know
that's very that would be a complex from
a union perspective
a complex would do that so it's a set of
values they're sort of autonomous they
inhabit you it's a sub personality it's
quite complex it's got something it's
aiming at you might not know even what
that is because you're acting it out
instead of understanding it and because
you're inside of it
it lays the world out for you in a
particular way it makes you it makes the
world look like it's showing you that
what you think is right
but it's just
you know if you're what do they say the
man with a hammer everything looks like
a nail right and that's that's
that's one of the things that's so damn
cool about that experiment it's like
really i'm really that blind i can miss
something that radical
just when i'm involved in some dopey
task like counting basketballs it makes
me so blind that it's almost beyond
comprehension
well so in some ways you you know you
skip between different states of
blindness a lot of them are biologically
motivated
then you turn those into a hierarchy and
that's sort of your higher value system
and then that thing points you with
something and the whole world lays
itself out around that and the way it
does it is it divides the world into
irrelevant things
and so those would have been the
curtains in this particular example or
the gorilla or even the player in black
who left the game irrelevant because it
didn't interfere with you counting
so what you look at makes most of the
world irrelevant
it makes some things
things that serve you and that makes you
feel positive emotion and it makes other
things things that get in your way and
that's what makes negative emotion and
so you've got the hypothalamic systems
that point you in biological directions
you organize those and then
it's like as you're approaching the
thing you're aiming at
the positive emotion systems tell you
when you're on track and the negative
emotion systems tell you when
something's interfering and those are
actually different neurological systems
so they're not in the hypothalamus the
positive emotion system is to some
degree but the negative emotion system
that that evolved later and there's a
couple of them there's one that produces
pain we'll talk about it more and
there's another one that produces
anxiety and so
also now you kind of understand the
relation roughly the relationship
between motivation
perception
and emotion you know they all act
together
and they're all dependent in this weird
way and on what you're after
so that you can think about that for 50
years and you won't get to the bottom of
it you know the buddhists say that
everything is illusion maya right people
live in illusion why because what you're
aiming at determines what you see
so
anyways
it's worth